hi everybody today we're going to talk
about optimizing file storage for your
use case I'm tad hunt and I manage the
file storage portfolio in Google Cloud
I'm a few goals for this talk first you
walk away with an understanding that
Google Cloud is ready for your
applications that need file storage
second if you're migrating file
workloads to cloud you understand that
you don't have to re are connect for
alternative storage solutions
correspondingly if you are running
workloads in cloud that might benefit
from file you know now I know how to
take advantage of it and finally this
knowledge enables you to simplify and
accelerate your public library we're
gonna to set some early context so you
can get the most out of your time we'll
start with an overview of why file is
important then deep dive into file store
and a couple of key file partnerships
and then we'll wrap it up by tying it
all together
so first the file landscape so let's
start by answering a question where do I
store my data in a taxonomy of storage
systems we generally break it down into
structure ie databases and unstructured
storage systems generally file block and
object file storage is generally focused
on unstructured data storage problems
and is critically important for
enterprise applications like s AP
infrastructure like VMware and all sorts
of things in between
since this is an intermediate level talk
I'm going to assume you're somewhat
familiar with shared file storage
commonly known as Nass or network
attached storage if you've made it this
far chances are that you have a file
storage problem that you need to solve
in GCP so we will be focusing on file
capabilities use cases and workloads it
all starts here shared file systems are
the are the arteries of enterprise
applications when the public cloud is
born it didn't have traditional file
services it had brand-new cool stuff
like object storage which enabled
brand-new use cases and application
architectures but lack of shared file
services meant that it the cloud just
was not ready for most enterprise
applications today Google cloud is ready
we offer a mature set of file storage
services both natively and from
industry-leading partners
look we all know that file workloads are
incredibly varied and as a consequence
there's not a single best file storage
solution for all use cases this view you
see here is one way to slice and dice it
sometimes GCP is offering file store
will be the best choice and sometimes
it'll be a partner offering for these
reasons we're committed to supporting a
strong partner ecosystem eliminating
friction from cloud migrations often
means providing the same tools in the
cloud as customers already using
on-premise usually do the advanced
features their applications depend on
our partners complement file store with
things like extreme scale at capacity
and performance rich and deep feature
sets with long histories baked deeply
and enterprise infrastructure support
for a hybrid cloud and container storage
the ability to stitch together many
distributed sites and of course there's
many more we believe that a capable
Google offering coupled with a strong
partner ecosystem recruits the best
expertise across the industry to solve
the problems you care about the end
result is you get the best solution for
your problem and we can't hope to cover
everything today so we're gonna focus on
a few examples where some of these
different solutions excel so that's the
landscape next let's dive into how file
store fits let's start with how one of
our file store customers is leveraging
file store to enable their business file
store has been generally available since
April 2019 and flywheel has been along
for the ride there are huge fans because
their WordPress hosting business depends
on reliable and performant file storage
file store provides that while
simultaneously enabling flyable to get
out of the storage infrastructure
management business
what is file store good at so more than
this of course but some of the keywords
that we've already tuned file store are
meteor rendering application migrations
web content management which is what
flywheel is doing media processing and
software development and testing so how
do we help customers like flywheel or
for that matter you focus on your
business we make it easy to pick the
right file store tear for your workload
by offering two flavors first we have
file store basic which is generally
available and has been since April 2019
and we just launched file store high
scale to beta in June so just you know
not too long ago if you're watching this
in July so file store basic is optimized
for enterprise workloads that don't have
large capacity and performance demands
but they do require enterprise class
reliability whereas high scale is
optimized for use when performance and
scalability are really critical to your
applications you may be aware that last
August we acquired a company called a
last two file high scale is our first
file store product built by the
integrated team and it's based on the
last file file system so let's talk for
a minute about performance file store
offers great latency I ops and
throughput as I like to say the trifecta
of storage performance equally is
important not only do you get great
performance but you get consistent
performance too this enables
predictability for your applications we
offer three file store performance tiers
to optimize for workloads with different
performance needs for example if your
workload is a low traffic enterprise app
say a web app with little usage you
might deploy a file store basic instance
HPD instance on the other hand may be of
a render farm built on preemptable VMs
with thousands of nodes and ten
thousands of cores you might pick high
scale to minimize your render times or
maybe your app is somewhere in between
maybe you're an intense random read or
random right workload but you've only
got a few clients maybe like a Monte
Carlo simulation for a single user maybe
that is the right signal to pick file
store basic that's that's deep in order
to get the maximum single client by ops
so we didn't just make file store fast
we also made it simple to reason about
the price and the performance that you
get when performance and capacity are
the key needs
file store high scale fits the bill for
those of you with advanced file system
knowledge file store basic is a scale up
architecture while file store high scale
is a scale out architecture what this
means is that high scale performance
scales linearly with capacity and it can
handle an enormous number of clients
with all of our file store tiers you
just pick it to your in a size I
creation time so that you know
immediately what your performance
characteristics are and since we don't
charge for operation fees you'll also
know immediately what your spend will be
and we even show you an estimate in the
console so Harvard selected the elasto
file based Google file store for it's
extremely powerful performance
customization capabilities and
simplicity of use this is an example of
where file store high scale has helped
Harvard with kovat 19 research they've
been doing virtual screening of
potential kovat 19 treatments and it
found some promising candidates through
this research we've got a really
extensive write-up about this on our
launch blog that's linked here this is a
good example of a batch compute workload
where file stores scale out performance
helps with high throughput computing
workers which it's kind of a good segue
into our tech specs since we're getting
a little bit technical anyway first I'm
gonna cover kind of you know just all of
what I'm showing you here I'm not going
to read just read the slide to you so
first file store is a zonal service it
offers an SLA of three nines for the
basic tiers which when twice scale
launches to GA will also match in high
scale with five star basic you can grow
up to 60 40 and high-skill that extends
that up to 322 you don't have to start
with a large filer because for all of
these variants of file store you can
actually grow on line with no doubt on
demand now for protocol support we've
got you covered with NFS which is kind
of the Linux you know industry-leading
protocol we also include file locking
and this is true across all tiers I
would say generally NFS can sometimes
work for Microsoft Windows workloads but
most of the time we would recommend a
partner offering and I'll talk about
that a little bit later if you have a
Windows workbook this is a Google
product so you get kind of Google grade
encryption and you know security you
know you could name Krypton at rest we
also recently rolled out beta support
for per IP range and a vest security
controls if you're an NFS expert this
next what I'm about to say will mean
something to you otherwise you'll be
like yeah so anyway an NFS has the
ability to set this thing called root
squash and of course read-only export
modes I think it's pretty explanatory
root squash is a
user ID mapping so that you can make
sure that route on the client is not
allowed to access the file system and do
some remapping there
we're also integrated with stackdriver
which enables you to set up alerts for
example a free space gets too low or you
deleted a bunch of data and you realize
you're wasting on you know a lot space
and also when you have application
performance issues we have a whole host
of i/o metrics that you can look at to
help you identify why your applications
might be performing as well as as they
should be finally there's three ways to
configure manage file store you can do
it through the command line through the
eight the standard Google Cloud API and
of course we've got the web console this
is obviously a brief overview of what
file store offers so check out our Doc's
at the link here for more details moving
on from the core file features I want to
talk about some of the integrations some
of the highlights here are for compute
engine we support great fully support
preemptable VMs which are commonly used
to optimize costs for batch workloads in
kubernetes engine we you can use file
store automatically and configure it
automatically through the native NFS
plug-ins through the CSI interface as
well on the networking side file store
is paired with your V PC network and
that enables you to access it from
authorized clients on that network and
then based on the IP access control
feature I mentioned on the prior slide
you can further restrict which of those
VMs on your you can see are allowed to
access it we talked about stack driver
already and then last but not least for
the config is code in the infrastructure
as code models were that many
enterprises are using today we're
integrated with deployment manager and
terraform so moving on all right so
let's say that your workload sits into
one of the files for tears
you know you've decided that you've
checked it out it seems to fit the bill
one of the next things on your mind is
probably is it where I should you know
can I put where do I have to put my app
to take advantage of it for fast or
basic the answer is anywhere Google
Cloud has a region you can use it there
where in all the regions for high scale
we just launched and we're already in
one region in each of the
as European and Asian markets and will
you know as the product matures will of
course show up in more places I should
note that this is a point in time view
from July 2020 if you're watching this
in the far future and you need high
scale and a region not listed here you
know check out the docs
yeah chances are things have changed at
any point in time if you do think that
high scale is what you need it is not
available and you need it please just
reach out to your account manager to
discuss options they can get in touch
with me and my team and and we can
probably hook you up I'm going to wrap
up the file store section by just
briefly covering a couple of backup
partner integrations and then we're
going to move on to other file partner
integrations the first is ACTU Pheo sky
which provides application consistent
backup in recovery and here's some
information and some links for you to
check out more and then we'll move on to
convo which is designed to protect data
residing in cloud file store and many
other you know their own vault and act
if you are both very well known partner
offerings for for backups convo enables
efficient and secure backups via their
compression deduplication and encryption
engines and they enable recovery to any
cloud file store instance or you can
even restore your data directly to any
windows products computers and that
about wraps it up for a file store
before we move on to talk about our file
partnerships the links here will help
help you jump in to get started with
provisioning and managing a or file
store instances
so moving on to file partners as I
mentioned in the landscape section we
integrate with partners for a wide range
of use cases and that means we work with
way too many partners that for me to
cover in one one overview video for this
talk I'll focus on dell emc and NetApp
because these are the two partners we've
integrated most deeply into the platform
so for example they're integrated
directly into our cloud console for
provisioning and managing of your file
systems they're integrated into cloud
billing so you get a single bill from
Google with everything on it and they're
integrated with cloud support so you
don't have to guess at who to reach out
to if you have an issue you just contact
us like like you would anything else if
your use case doesn't seem to be covered
by Dell or NetApp for example you might
have a low latency HPC workload that
relies on muster or maybe you have a
branch office workload where you've got
out you know thousand branch offices
that all need access to the same file
for collaboration or anything else at
file store or one of these two partners
doesn't seem to be a good fit for please
reach out to us through your account
manager and well you know we have a like
I mentioned before we'll help you get
started with the right solution so let's
jump in with Dells new offering
previously you might have known this
this next product I'm going to describe
as Isilon or one FS but Dell just went
through a rebranding exercise to bring
all of the EMC product branding in line
with the rest of the Dell ecosystem and
going forward it's not just called power
scale still the same goodness inside
just with the new name so power scale
for Google cloud launched a general
availability just a couple of months ago
this past May it provides an enterprise
class native cloud experience for
enabling organizations to accelerate
innovation for high performance
applications such as analytics media
entertainment and life sciences
power scale is built on the mature
Isilon 1fs file system and all of its
capabilities are now available in GCE
additionally the fact that this is a
managed service brings some things you
don't get on-premises namely you get an
SLA experts from Google and Dell who
manage the service so you don't have to
and you're billed only for what you use
you don't have to pre buy a whole bunch
of space like you do on Prem because
hard drives are large for more
information or how to get started then
you can visit the link here or you know
just search Google works pretty well too
that's this is gonna be a really brief
overview of these couple of partners so
next up we're going to dive into net up
Dell has one really big offering and
that up really has two offerings they
have clouds volume service and we'll
talk about that and cloud volumes on tap
one is a managed service and one is a
self- switch we're going to start with
cloud volume service private value
service has been GA since October 2019
it's a fully managed storage solution
delivering high performance and low
latency for application workloads such
as sa Piana
google cloud vmware engine and microsoft
windows if you note it if you remember
from before when I said file store is
not great for Microsoft Windows
workloads you know one of these partner
offerings is they both have very very
mature Microsoft Windows fax that
protocol is called SMB so that very
mature indeed stacks so NetApp cloud
volume service was designed with the
application owner in mind it looks and
feels like a native Google service
including the integrations in there the
console the billing and support that I
mentioned before and then in addition of
that it has three different price
performance tiers as well as the ability
to scale performance dynamically up and
down with your application and user
requirements this ensures that your
application is right-sized through
development and test and production
lifecycle additionally it comes with an
SLA of three nines which means it's
ready for your production use business
and then here's the link to get more
information or you get started on netapp
second service is called cloud volumes
on top so when your needs extend beyond
the capabilities of cloud volume service
product I just talked about
NetApp also offers cloud volumes on tap
is a self managed storage solution so it
delivers nearly the entire set of
storage management and data optimization
capabilities available to your on from
yo to on-premise meta on tap users today
so if you're coming from on-premise and
you and you're already relying on a lot
of meta features this might be a good
offering for you it's really designed
for storage administrators so that are
familiar with Annette app on tap
operating system it provides a seamless
method to accelerate migration of you
your on-premise application workloads as
well as ensure your on-premise data is
protected safely in the cloud for
archive and disaster recovery these
cases again for more information or to
get started check out this link here
and that kind of brings us to the end at
this point we're gonna wrap it up so you
know going back to the the intro you
know tying it all together shared file
systems are the arteries of enterprise
applications and everything we've
covered can be boiled down to the fact
that GCP is ready for these workloads I
started with my goals for this talk
which are that you walk away
understanding that not only have Google
clouds file capabilities matured but now
you have some idea of how to leverage
them to simplify and accelerate your
public cloud file storage stream thank
you I hope this talk has helped light
the path thanks for your time